how exciting is it to be pawned that all
from Blackwell because it's really been
loved about the fans and the critics as
well hasn't it it has in like I said
before we didn't think this many people
would be into our show I mean we felt
like we were shooting something special
when we were first doing it but you know
it's it's we've developed quite the cult
following and having that kind of cult
following in that dedication from our
fans is it's just continuing that this
the word-of-mouth is making our fandom
grow and it's really interesting to see
how dedicated our fans are and to see be
a be a part of such a show that we all
feel is very special and that's
translating to the fans is very special
as well when I read the first script I I
knew instantly that it was going to be
something special our writers are
brilliant they're so smart and they're
so in tune with the real world and
what's really going on and and they're
not afraid to take risks so as an actor
you don't really have to do too much
work because it's there on the page but
it's also you know our show wouldn't be
anything as good as it is without the
brilliance of Tatiana maslany
jumping in and out of all these
different characters so you know it's
I'm ecstatic to be a part of this show
and it's just getting better and better
I think we set the bar extremely high
for ourselves in season one and I think
season two we've exceeded that so it's
it's it's it's a real blessing to be a
part of it as an actor I think Tatiana
has really taken it to the next level
she's just getting better better which
is you know it's it's I can't believe
that girl has the kind of stamina that
she does because she's playing against
herself in a lot of scenes and to do
what she's doing is nothing short of
miraculous
I think the story is getting more
interesting it's getting bigger it's
it's you know and like I said with the
fans that it just seems like our shows
just keeps gaining momentum and keeps
gaining steam so bigger and better was
our was our you know we're not afraid to
take chances I guess is is what I like
too you know I explained how explain how
our show is and how our show runners are
and also you know BBC America is very
supportive as a network and they give a
lot of creative freedom so I think that
makes the show a lot more interesting
just talking about your character shady
shady mix shade stir you
yeah I mean see you I mean what's been
the best thing about playing this
character over two seasons then because
you can never put you can never put your
thumb on him as to what he is really
like where his loyalties lie he's a very
cold calculating methodical kind of guy
but at the same time he has a softer
side and I think that's what makes our
show great you never know where our
characters true intentions lives whereas
two feelings are whereas true loyalties
are and I think that's one of the
brilliance of war from black because you
never know which way any one of our
characters are going to go they're
always swaying on both sides of the
fence so that's I think which you know
is captivating about our show and really
draws people in how do you like to see
that character developing um I you know
I put full faith and trust in the
writers as far as character development
I you know they're vey the witch they're
brilliant as well because they give you
know they're they're not just writing
the character as they see how he should
be written they actually you know look
to you for some creative input as well
so I really like the Orpah that I'm in
in season two with the new clone Rachel
as well as dr. leekie I think it's a
very fun and different interesting orbit
to be in and I just you know where
there's a lot more surprises coming up
so I was really pleased with how this
season ended without giving away too
much why would you like to see the
relationship with Sarah okay um you know
it's a very tumultuous relationship
currently he still feels some what
responsible for what happened to Beth
the character Beth so with that he sees
redemption through Sarah and also he has
feelings for Sarah but at the same time
you know she has a lot on her plate I
don't know if she the the feelings are
reciprocal so you know he's looking out
for number one and he's a guy that's
always gonna look out for number one but
I really love the dynamic between Paul
and Sarah and I hope you know hope it'll
be explored more but at the current time
she did pistol-whip him in the face and
sees episode 1 of season 2 so she's also
back with her baby's daddy
so he's in a very precarious position
involving Sarah but you know he does
feel some sort of loyalty and hurt over
you know over what happened and he he's
definitely
more loyal to her but we'll see have a
favorite episode I do I would have to
say my favorite from season 1 was
variations under domestication which is
episode 6 which is the potluck at
Alison's house I thought that was the
perfect blend of comedy drama dark
comedy thriller thriller you know all
the above I think that episode had it
all and I think it was very fun to put a
nail gun to someone's head and very
psychotic part of Paul you know the
interrogating part of my character I
thought that was fun that he was finally
able to kick some butt
as far as season 2 is concerned my
favorite episode would have to be the
the final episode of season 2 and so far
so far I mean you mentioned before it's
obviously it's a characters cold is
calculating yes my self-interested is
those qualities you can relate to
yourself because you seem a little bit
more happy in smiling I know everybody
when they first meet me they're like you
are so different than your character on
television which i think is thank you
very much because I'm not to stalk of an
individual I seem do like emote more
emotion than this guy was but at the
same time that's why this character is
the way he is is because you know his
backstories he's killed six Marines in a
friendly fire it's in and so I I took it
as he's suffering from some sort of post
PTSD and I you know I I you know he's
he's a yeah he's got a lot of inner
turmoil so and I think he doesn't a moat
a lot as well he's a lot of the stage
directions in the script are Paul best
poker face Paul putting on his best
poker face so that's why he's very you
know very stone-faced a lot of the times
but I think that's going to change at
the end of the season you know I think
you're going to see a little more
emotion of this character but yeah I
couldn't be further from this character
and that's why they call it acting don't
they I mean you mentioned that they
asked you for input on the characters is
there anything you feel what you've
particularly contributed all kind of
directions that you kind of push them to
take well I always say I want to kick
more but I say I want more fighting
scenes I want more you know more guns
blazing all that kind of stuff so that
hasn't
and yet so I don't know if they're
definitely they're necessarily taking my
words advice to eat but yeah I think
dicks you know sir would your character
say this what do you say how would he
say it would he say it this way would he
say it that way so it's more like on in
return in terms of the lines and if
we're saying the right thing so but I
definitely put my two cents in
like I want facial hair I think I want
to speak with a lower voice I think it
shows more gravitas and more more
sinister when a character has a lower
voice so yeah little things like that
LeMans this is like that they agree with
so I mean we talked about favorite
episodes but for you favorite characters
apart from your own who do you just love
Lucia
oh well I love I love Felix I think
Felix is fantastic and Jordan Guevara so
I think plays him brilliantly I
personally have never heard an American
while Canadians Canadian but he has
spent some time in the States do a
better British accent and then he does I
really am in love with the clone Hellena
I think she's one of those characters
that you you know you just feel for and
she's also she's also a psychopathic
killer or what sure which makes her very
interesting but for some reason you just
drawn to her and you feel sorry for and
I love Alison because I grew up in the
suburbs and being in the suburbs I think
I've come across quite a few soccer moms
in my day that probably have acted like
Alison those would probably be my top
three we've had 70 great coins on the
show so far what kind of clothes would
you like to see going forward if you
could have any title any type of clone I
would like to have a Paul Terminator
clone I think that would be fantastic
I would say from Terminator 2 I can't
remember the actor's name but he was the
liquid guy me yes yes Robin Patrick
that's right I would love I love that
because you know Paul goes to Taiwan
with Rachel and maybe you know maybe
there's some new technology over there
or we can make a Paul liquid clone of
whatever kind of look what he was made
of I don't remember but you know I think
a Felix clone would be fantastic
also maybe maybe an art clone you know I
love the character art I don't think
Kevin hancher gets enough credit because
I think he's the more
a compass of the show and I think him
his character going in a different
direction to seeing clone of him go in a
completely different direction you play
it beautifully because I think he's a
fantastic actor more than us or Phoenix
claim we like do you think uh I don't
know I think I think Jordan can play
Butch pretty well so I think you know I
think that'd be very interesting to see
him on the different end of the spectrum
and an art clone I don't know Kevin's
got a lot of swag you can pull anything
off so I think they both be brilliant
in terms of the genre what do you think
so I find fantasy I mean what we see
here surrounded by great people and from
a lot of great shows today but do you
think it gives audiences and performers
they don't get from working in just kind
of contemporary drama
no no that's well I think art our our
show is sci-fi based in reality because
cloning is a real thing right and it's
not like we have aliens and all sorts of
crazy spaceships and stuff like that in
our show which i think is fantastic but
our show is more like a realistic sci-fi
show but as far as the broad spectrum of
sci-fi shows I think it's you know it's
it's it's a world of fantasy that I
think is a lot of people like to escape
into so I think sci-fi is a great realm
for for television viewers and I'm a big
fan of sci-fi as well a big fan of
Battlestar Galactica I love lost you
know is if lost you've lost is
considered a size a sci-fi type of show
alias was kind of sci-fi too sci-fi ish
yeah I know it's it's just it's a
wonderful thing because you don't see
dramas having big conventions and
comedies having big conventions like
this so the fandom out there definitely
loves their sci-fi so it's interesting
it's very interesting what else is
coming up for you at the moment where
else we can see uh you're gonna see me
I'm in a Lifetime movie called petals on
the wind which is based on the VC
Andrews books that were almost like The
Hunger Games of their times in the early
80s starring Heather Graham and the
Magnificent Ellen Burstyn I have a
pretty prominent role on that I just
shot a pilot for Robert Rodriguez the
director called Matador which is about
Latino James Bond and I had a lot of fun
doing that being in a Robert Rodriguez
action action sequence because that was
something I really wanted to do so I can
Chuck that check that off the bucket
list what was it like working with
Robert he's fantastic
he's brilliant he's probably the most
under earth laid-back guy he's got his
guitar on sad always strumming mariachi
tunes and you know Nolan does action and
gore better than Robert Rodriguez so
it's definitely was a blessing and I was
I was pinching myself when I was telling
sad every day and if I get picked up for
a series would we be seeing more of you
in that uh the possibility yes but my
obligations live with or from black so
you have a message for fans before you
leave us I do thank you so much for
making orphan black what it is clone
Club you're the best you rock and we
love you
you